доброго дня шеннон не журналісти я
хотіла
швидкість 100 тис. чоловіки вас за вашу
їжу кумолу
донести інформацію протез що вчора раз
путча вся конкурс на члені та наука ви
і раді національній радість поталь
розвитку наука та технології чому
і кутила серця відривала тиш Ісус
пильний ріст волосся отрута ви знаєте саме
новий закон про наука війна у кого
технічний геніальність передача та новий
колегіальний орган управління наукою у
який би до навчання у цій прем'єр-міністр
запасу duets та національна рада
випробувань розвитку наука та технології
все заради будди розумний і
адміністративний комітет і хочу сказати
ще царя пологах біля дому ти душа великої
флек на російську фінансово не й у науці
на ви значення стратегічних
пріоритетів
тя члени наука ви і раді будучи так вже
ти ми хто факти що будуть але мінвати
людей США проти ти мули в національ
національному фоні сліди
національний фонд сліди проти таміно
боягуз у справах грантового фінансування
для фундаментальних та прикладних чи дасть
джейн про g.na зводжу його за краще ти dots
їх радий чесних принципів на кофті і
тому
ми шляху лиж об'єктної беша кільки з
кандидатів які ж бачиш
кваліфікаційним ви магам за крима їх
участі розвитку нові сфери України
гарну
без доган мою репутацію наукову гру
мати заспіваю
їхати почні а подій наука with a una у
кого організацій незабудкою
ви знання
паховим спі нотами до sweet експертної
ідеальності так їх початку не в наукі
і раді ми моєму назад 24 конкурс буде
риба ти на продаж місяця факти що
wimboot і завершу в сад 10 травня та 25
травня мою чеку йому про голос це
результат цього конкурсу я хочу нога
дати що ти ми хто буде про б радий
члени валкові ради
ідентифікаційний комітет z9 осип над
випадково авторитетних наука птахів сиру
диких чиститися іноземці та троє
українських наук вівці вики про броню
спи ноту і наукова usa душ іжорської ми
критеріями там ми вже вистачило
щоб цей конкурс виду все про зору що в
ньому взяв і вчать усіх там а ити бажання
потім працювати всі ми важливі вам у
органі правда вся робота на грам пекельних
засадах там в одному з критеріїв до
таких
кандидатів здалися і при прийнятті
рішень опротестовані будуть проти ти
на храм пекельних засадах у такому розумному
у такому науковому комітеті ж хоч
і локшина гадот і що в ти національній
rogue крем наукова комітету їжте
адміністративний комітет віку каламутиш
буду 24 особи алла ті люди будуть nomi
новій ниві центральних органів влади
вид академії наук вид iнших органів та
ідея була в тому, щоб ми вивели на один
майдан шик наука fcew і ти хто приймає
вас останні рішення для того, щоб всі
рішення щодо розвитку наука
побачив і пріоритетом розвитку України
то економіки та розум стоїмо при прийнятті
стратегічних рішень походжала
задум авторитетних наук вівці
від же прошутто допоміг ти нам раз усюди
цієї інформації про тещу стартувавши
конкурс до наукового комітету національні
раді випробувань розвитку наукою та
технологією я співаю